por fuera parece un día tranquilo pero
un piso más arriba se trabaja contra el
reloj para conseguir plazas en las
unidades de cuidados intensivos estamos
gestionando nuevas camas para tener la
demanda vinicius trabajar de sol a sol
para salvar vidas
río de janeiro suma 20.000 muertos de
los 300.000 registrados en todo el país
en las últimas dos semanas la media de
fallecidos creció un 67 por ciento
este equipo hace la captación de plazas
identifica las camas vacías en nuestra
red y las pone a disposición para los
médicos reguladores
lo que nos preocupa desde el inicio de
la pandemia es que el aumento de casos
sea a grupo sea todo a la vez
desde esta central los enfermos más
graves son enviados a hospitales como
este que es una referencia en la región
aquí los pacientes intubados son cada
vez más jóvenes
había muchas camas vacías que se han
llenado en las últimas dos semanas lo
que acontece muchas veces es que el
paciente no consigue llegar hasta
nosotros por una cuestión de
vulnerabilidad familiar o social de
habilidades sociales no conseguir en
casa ellos no consiguen tener acceso a
los servicios sanitarios entonces no
tenemos la noción real de los casos que
están aconteciendo porque muchos de
ellos ni conseguimos tratarlos muchos
pueden morir antes en sus casas
otra preocupación es la posible falta de
oxígeno
esta empresa abastece los principales
hospitales públicos y privados de río
están en contacto permanente con las
autoridades sanitarias para poder
satisfacer una demanda que crece cada
día es persona gotas espero que no haya
un colapso en río pero si lo hay
vamos a traer oxígeno desde otras
ciudades que están mejor para darnos
este apoyo a los dos y eso por seguir el
viernes rio de janeiro empieza un lock
down de 10 días para intentar contener
el avance de la pandemia para ello es
necesario que los ciudadanos colaboren y
que las playas queden así desiertas